Let's talk for a moment about this metric of time between selections.
Suppose that an Airhead is selected.
Followed by a Starburst.
Followed by two Hershey's.
Followed by an Airhead again.
Let's define the number of candies that come between two Airhead selections as
the interselection time between Airheads.
So if someone were to choose an Airhead here,
there would be zero turns in between Airhead selections.
If someone were to choose an Airhead here, there would be one turn,
two turns, and so on.
Until here, where someone actually chose an Airhead again.
We have an interselection time of 4 turns between Airhead selections.
And just to reiterate, the interselection time for
a candy c is the number of turns between selections of that candy c.